so while you're at the farm you know
that there's going to be
some rules that we have to follow just
out of
respect and i'm not sure how your
culture
handles this but we thought it'd be a
really good idea to
let you have your own room
explain you stay
your own i stay different room
what do you think about i don't i don't
i don't like it
end
and um our house kind of our rules
i don't really have a choice
i definitely feel somewhat blindsided i
was gonna tell julia
like after she had time to settle in you
know
and my mom just comes out and drops it
right on her
you're not seeing me before he wasn't
being honest
shame on you
you do agree with what your mother is
talking about
don't you i mean what
um i think it sucks but
yeah i mean i understand it's hurt
y'all's house
she'll not say no for parents
him say yes of course he need to
try talk with parents say i think we
need like this because
my life i am not young boy and this is
my new wife
and this is life
just until you get married we feel it's
just a respect you know what you're
doing tomorrow
i'm digging a tunnel going again
you go murder tomorrow
no i don't have a problem with you
married i don't have a problem
can we also have children then speaking
of children
speaking of children you guys
do not want children right away right
yes we're not thinking about children
now okay
so you're you're gonna take proper steps
to make sure that there are no children
yet
we don't plan children now we plans
maybe after
two years three yes but
i mean you're making sure you have
adequate
expression for brandon this is my life
and him life
it's not life for parents